foreign
lots of love today and plenty of
questions we're going to start with
Lindsay with an E I've gotten so
accustomed to my current lifestyle that
things like Netflix HBO Max Etc are hard
to let go of how do we decide what to
cut out when things are already
accounted for in your budget I'm not
going to tell you how to do it Lindsay
but I'll tell you how I do it I will do
the scorched Earth approach you've heard
of burning Fields right it doesn't have
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
often burning field so when Farmers burn
Fields so they can re-plan it it
re-fertilizing the land give it a break
to start from scratch and so I did this
recently with my subscription Services I
got rid of Netflix and Hulu I got rid of
Paramount plus and Apple TV and YouTube
premium and Spotify and apple music and
Pandora and title yes I had title as
well I had all of these streaming
services and so there was probably
probably around a dozen 1314 streaming
services that over the top over time I
had accumulated it didn't all happen at
once and so what did I do I got rid of
all of them a hundred percent of them
and then I just waited I didn't wait a
month or a year or whatever I just said
all right I'm gonna give myself some
time when do I miss it immediately
YouTube premium I needed that back
because I hate advertisements
advertisements suck let's get rid of all
of these advertisers so I brought that
back and then oh yeah you know what I do
listen to a lot of music Apple music
made sense to me the streaming platform
great did that and then I waited waited
waited ah you know I don't really need
this I don't miss that at all I don't
miss Hulu I and all of a sudden you
realize like oh I only have two or three
or four streaming services now but I've
cut 10 of them out of my life and by
doing this regularly you don't have to
just do it with that but anything that's
in your budget if you have this giant
budget with a hundred monthly expenses
and you got down to zero would you
repurchase these monthly subscriptions
starting today and if you don't feel
compelled to do so let them go I love
that you and like what it started with
was getting rid of your internet when
you move up to Ventura County so like
that was really the foundation of like
well I don't have internet now so I'm
probably not going to need these
different Services
um so yeah I mean I would say you could
even take it a step further
um what what I've been practicing uh my
buddy taught me this
um you can watch whatever you need to
watch on HBO Max or Paramount whatever
the streaming services that Lindsay
mentioned there and then you can cancel
your subscription and then if there's
something else you want to watch you
could sign back up for a month or two
later they would love for you to sign
back up in fact sometimes they give you
a better deal when you when they win
back a customer so um yeah I mean maybe
that's a middle ground for you Lindsay
like when's the last time you watched
HBO match when's the last time you
watched Paramount plus and uh yeah turn
them off and turn them on when you want
to use them or never turn them on again
if you don't yeah yeah that's good you
just made me think about Spotify like I
gotta I want to be cool I want to be
cool so bad Josh
Spotify is inferior right so oh is it
not cool anymore I'm not saying that
it's way cooler but isn't that how it
works many of the cooler things are
inferior oh yeah apple music's uh the
with the lossless audio their audio as
long as you have it all turned on in the
settings their audio is so much better
than spotify's it's not even close what
does it say about me because like I was
just at at my aunt's place and I'm
talking to my little cousin she's like
13 she had a friend over her friend was
like 13 years old and they're listening
to Spotify and
um if I mention Pandora they look at me
like I'm a dinosaur like Pandora oh is
that on the radio back in the day
Grandpa anyway but what does it say
about me though like I really do hold on
to Spotify because I'm like yeah I am
cool I'm using with the kids for years
I use it to listen to Rogan every once
in a while but yeah um yeah I need to I
need to rethink some of these other
services I have too for sure I'm glad
this this topic I brought up Ryan's
walking in a row with the baseball cap
to the side hello fellow kids
with the back back on
what's up peeps
so have you discovered anything that's
the bomb lately
what's popping
one quick thing I'll say about this is
that there are fewer things we
underestimate more than our ability to
be happy without the things we already
wish we could get rid of and so a good
example of this is think about uh
compulsive habits or addictions you know
things that you just want to stop doing
stuff that you want to stop eating when
you're thinking about it hypothetically
oh but will I be able to live without
that that that pleasure that comfort
that luxury and and you already wish
that you could but you don't get to
experience that power and that Clarity
and that lightness and that freedom
until you do get rid of it right and so
I would suggest that Scorch Earth
technique where you say this I'm going
to get rid of them all and maybe I have
five of them and I'm gonna say I have
the permission to keep something like
one or two but here's my rule the next
thing I want to watch
if I sign up for it that's the thing I
gotta keep so if a movie comes out and I
want to watch it on Disney plus okay I
can sign up for Disney plus but if I do
that that's the one I'm keeping for a
year and that cost will make you say oh
do I really want Disney Plus for the
sake of this one movie or do I want to
wait on something I feel more excited
about it'll just introduce an element of
critical thinking to it that you might
find helpful did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]